well joining me now to discuss all is if
time's ready a broadcaster and author
Mariana Frost job ITV political editor
an author of the crash a thrilling new
novel Robert peston and author of the
war on the West Douglas Murray over in
New York let me start with you Douglas
because I've not had to take yet from
from New York what's the mood there
because Russell Brand's a big name in
America big Hollywood star of course uh
big media figure there as well how has
this gone down in America
well you see he's big in America he he
is famous but uh he's not a big Talent
uh his attempt to break Hollywood some
years ago was was a flop uh everyone
recognizes that and it's been argued
that his more recent trajectory into the
sort of fever swamps of conspiracy
theory or sort of result of that he
tried his career in the UK he came to
America to try to do it didn't work and
then he became this sort of
self-appointed Guru who most recently
could be found on his YouTube channel
claiming that the Maui fires were
arguably started by BlackRock lasers
although there was no evidence for that
but there wasn't any evidence not for it
either I mean this was this was for
anyone unfamiliar with it the territory
that he had he had got himself into so
there's enormous interest in it of
course as there is in all of these media
stories uh but it's not the case that
he's regarded as any kind of talent
Marella
I read this report in the Sunday Times
then I watched the dispatches thing I
think you've got to do that to make any
measured judgment about where we are
with this it seemed to me with my former
newspaper editor hat on incredibly well
researched investigative journalism
obviously gone through many layers of
fact checking and legal work but
ultimately in some of the cases
certainly it will be a case of the word
of the person making the allegations
against Brands and he's vehemently
denied any criminality here
is it right that he should be
unceremoniously canceled by all these
companies before we've really got to a
conclusion on this
well my greatest surprise quite frankly
is that he's been allowed to broadcast
for as long as he has because if you
look back at you know some of the quotes
from his delightful Memoir my bookie
work then you'll find extremely
misogynistic extremely unsavory and I
would say in many cases alluding to an
issue on his part with what is and isn't
consensual well it's interesting you say
that so I I found an interview I did
with him in 2006 which is the same year
I think that he was going out with the
16 year old girl and picking her up from
school
um and it was a it was a a classic brand
interview at the time where I asked for
reasons that I'm not entirely sure other
than it must have been joking at the
time are you a more successful sexual
predator now you don't drink I meant it
as a joke I didn't have any information
about him actually being a sexual
predator he said yes but I resent the
word Predator I like to think of myself
as a conduit of natural forces after all
the most natural thing in the world for
people to do is to use the euphemism for
having sex and people want to do it he
said so all you have to do is remove all
the reasons why women don't actually go
through with it like pride and
reputation you just have to unpick the
conditions stopping women going straight
to bed with you and then he said this to
your point I asked him if he was
attracting more women since becoming a
celebrity he said actually always
changes the amount of Seduction required
has decreased to almost Preposterous
proportions now I'm famous I've always
been good at pulling because I'm quite
Charming but if I talk to 10 women in
the old days and I'd backed myself to
pull two or three now I wouldn't be
happy with less than eight or nine and
whereas I would have devoted a lot of
time to seduction depending on the
quality of the Target now I just get on
with it Fame has been very helpful in
that respect now these are damning but I
think quotes right I mean but that's a
damning question as well if you don't
mind because if you can say to him as a
joke question that you're a more
successful sexually I agree so now that
you don't drink I agree then actually
what it reflects is a culture where it's
acceptable to make joke books about
things that are incredibly I totally
agree and that for me is the biggest
issue with all of this you know if
criminal proceedings uh go ahead and if
he's found guilty that's that's a
completely separate thing and I'm not in
any way qualified to talk about that but
certainly as a woman who's been in the
public eye for the last 35 years you
know the the atmosphere and the ability
for people to use their power and to
promote themselves in a certain way and
to discuss and laugh about things that
really aren't funny I think began in the
kind of mid 90s with all those lad
magazines yeah I don't disagree and and
because we saw what happened with the
thing with Jonathan Ross with Paul uh
with the young woman Georgina Bailey was
on my show last night talking about the
effect that I had on her life
um Robert when he goes on to say he
boasts endlessly about the number of
women he slept with and so on but he
goes on to say that he uh treats women
as goddesses he never wants to be
misogynistic or aggressive towards I
mean he kind of qualifies it all as he's
often done leaving you sort of wondering
well what is the real Russell Brand here
and maybe from these investigations we
are finding out the Sinister reality but
maybe we're not I mean I do think if you
believe in due process if you believe in
the law doing his job it is too early to
convict it will I'm sure we'll
contributors to your show peers believe
in due process but on the other hand
you know there have been uh more than
rumors it's been a sort of Open Secret
in parts of the media for years the the
this this character uh was seen by women
who we'd had relationships with as
abusive
um and I mean you know my partner Sean
Edwards wrote in the standard a few
years ago uh about you know what an
appalling man he was in terms of his
relationships with women and she was
responding actually curiously uh to a
Sunday Times interview with him in which
he'd said he'd become a great supporter
of me too and I mean this was a sort of
I mean this was like an insult really
but there wasn't the outrage you would
have expected so I mean as many would
say yes it's great the channel for on
the Sunday Times have done an important
investigation about how some an
individual seems to have abused his
power uh as a result of his Fame
slightly ask yourself why weren't they
doing this year you know why why was he
being given respectability over many
years why was he in the investigation in
a sense so late I'm also I mean it's
interesting you know that Charlotte
writes this article but actually he's
written far more damning things well
yeah people have written about him I
mean if you look at these quotes from my
bookie book by my twenties I would
relish the challenge of chaste meds in
the search for the correct combination
of words required to decode their moral
resistance the obstacle course I call it
you know as I score escorted Michaela a
lap dancer he slapped him after sex
through the front door I felt very
strongly that I needed to avenge the
slap I spat in her face that's in his
words in his book totally and what's it
I do think you know one of the things
that all of the media both from tabloid
to uh sort of broadsheet and indeed
television everybody has questions to
answer here because everybody lends in
respectability in different ways you
know that you know I mean the news
tonight interview you know where he's
taken you know this is a man whose ideas
are absurd and yet you know the BBC
gives them a platform as though he's
something
to talk about the drug lords basically
prime minister because there's a there's
this ridiculous idea that somehow he's
this has this connection with young
people the guardian the guardian had
himself I mean Adam rossbridge has been
very pompous about this on Twitter and
very highfalutic he had him next to him
in the guardian editorial conference
sitting next to Ross Bridger and he's
dictating the water so I think how you
legitimize somebody how you give them
respectability how you give them this
cloak which allows them to do some
really terrible I think you know there
are questions for everybody
one other thing which I think is really
really important in all of this is that
we have to look at our own culture over
the last two decades and I feel so
strongly that the proliferation of
pornography which has been facilitated
by the World Wide Web has turned has
normalized Behavior I mean we were
joking about the 90s and and what that
was like but that was not aggressive and
it wasn't anything to do with violence
against women what's become normalized
amongst young people who've got had
their sex education delivered today
through the internet without any kind of
guidance is that this is normal because
that it is funny I mean if you listen to
clips of him doing live performances
where he's saying some of the vilest
things I've ever heard you'll hear men
and women laughing in the audience
because somehow you've got a standing
Innovation on the day this all dropped
that night on stage which I found very
disconcerting to watch I mean I would
make the point which we made yesterday
is that since the metoo and time's up
campaigns in particular a lot of this
stuff looking back to the kind of banter
as it was described at the time you know
he won the shagger of the Year award at
the Sun three years running everyone
thought that was funny right no one was
as morally outrageous they are now I do
think the moral uh conviction of brand
historically is pretty intense right now
and probably perfectly Justified
but I think that the way in which you
humiliate and disparage people and the
sorts of things that he's describing
yeah that's not about promises no let me
bring up about a blatant disregard of
women let me bring in Douglas again
listen patiently to this
I suppose the point about this is there
is a theory which we had a King's Castle
yesterday talking to us that all this
does all this social media speculation
all the Raging opinions on either side
they actually make it incredibly
difficult for him ever to face a fair
trial if he ever face a trial at all
therefore Justice itself doesn't get
served it gets damaged by this that's
another part of the equation
well look it there's some truth in that
I just wanted to return something that
Robert said earlier which is that first
of all it was a sort of Open Secret in
the media whenever the general public
discover there's a sort of Open Secret
in the media the general public always
asks well why did the media keep keep it
to itself yeah and it's a perfectly
legitimate question to ask and the
second question to ask it's a point to
make if I may is Robert said everyone
enabled him that's not true I can give a
list of the people who enabled him the
BBC Channel 4 the guardian that hostism
is a columnist as well as an attendance
editorial conferences the new Statesman
that made him the editor for one issue
and I so and this is important because
this was at the height of the
allegations that were made against him
at this same time if I may point out uh
Charles Moore at the Telegraph and The
Spectator pointed out that Russell
Brand's Behavior was so abhorrent at the
BBC that he would no longer pay the BBC
license fee it was not the case everyone
fell for this charlatan it was not the
case that everyone thought he was God's
gift and that he could swing an election
it was a very strange time on the
British left and it was the British left
that enabled him now and I could just
make this one point I don't want to be
partisan about this because there's a
non-part exam point but it is important
to note that as Russell Brand has in my
view given himself cover by fleeing to
this weird far-right conspiracy Place
almost nobody on the right of the
spectrum has welcomed I mean the
telegraph is not giving him guest
columns he is not being invited into the
editorial meetings of the telegraph
there is some responsibility that the
people who enabled him in Britain should
take instead of as always covering it
wild okay
you can't make this political then the
government government of the day and not
labor facilitated him and invited him to
speak at in Parliament about what should
be drug policy in this country how on
Earth he would have any sort of
credibility in that sphere I have no
idea the fact of the matter is that what
would dealing with is someone who is
clearly a sex predator
well he did he objected immediately he
said I resent the word Predator right so
he doesn't categorize he says he was
wildly promiscuous loved sex with
thousands of women uh but that's not a
crime right the question is has what
he's done actually become criminality
the Sunday Times he's been accused of
rape yeah he's been accused of crime
until she kissed me I lied and danced
and evoked the spirit of pan till
reluctantly she removed her bra I used
tears and emotional blackmail to secure
the immolation of her knickers I mean
you know I don't have to say anything
when did that book come out it came out
I think 2004 right but I don't remember
any action being taken about the book
right so I don't even know who published
it I'm not an expert on Russell Brand I
am an expert on sexism in society and I
don't think that you can call it in
either right wing or a left wing or
indeed
thing everywhere I'm not going to defend
Russell Brand I want to see how this
plays out
there is one small point just to pick up
something that Douglas said I was you
know in terms of who may be you know
right now one of the most absolutely
most powerful people in the world uh
definitely not on the left Elon Musk you
know uh said you know the competition no
no no no wonder they're coming after you
yeah so you know he has been endorsed by
people of all change shall we say but I
can think of a lot of rock stars he's
got Andrew Tate right behind him
when I first met in the music business
when you were a music video there were
lots of rock stars and pop stars who
were behaving just like Russell Brand
and boasting about it morals is unique
that's the tragedy that's what I'm
trying to say but why is a cultural
Society I think what's changed wild
Brazen boastful promiscuity by male
celebrities used to be celebrated it
definitely isn't now there's been a
shift in the way these are viewed morals
there has always been a line though you
know
can we just look at Andrew Tate and his
enormous success he boasts about his
sexuality all the time I mean it's not
it's not that it's a thing of the past
Russell Brand is the object of our ire
at the moment but what we're not doing
is Shifting the the the the whatever the
expression is you know we need to change
the culture no I totally agree I totally
agree very quickly appears very quickly
one very quick point to make for me
which is that there's a question of due
process here that you've rightly raised
and many people have been saying well
how could the girls in question the
young women question get a fair trial I
think that's an
incredibly important point to raise but
one of the answers is how few rape
accusations actually make it through not
just a trial into conviction and I would
like to see in our society not just
these high-profile celebrity related
cases going to trial and getting more
success but think of the hundreds of
girls in places like Telford who breaks
yeah yeah I want equal judges across the
board just on Celebrity cases yep I
totally agree I think we can all agree
on that I think I agree Robert you've
got a brilliant new thriller the crash
it's not the story of Russell Brand
although it could be
um
and the mainstream media on the back
couldn't be more excited by this you've
quoted every paper saying it's the
greatest book of all time give me a very
quick summary of what this is so it's a
story about the crash as it says it's
set in 2007 2008 a story that um I was
sort of someone immersed in and it's
basically about Central character
journalist at the BBC I wonder where I
got that idea from
um who's on off goes on off girlfriend
is found hanged in her flat uh the it's
a story about the abuse of power by
people at the top of big organizations
that we've just been talking about at
his quest to find out uh why she died
excellent and he's taken all the sexy
bits out on the advice
they just aren't sex scenes
thank you very very much indeed uh thank
you to Douglas